bonsoir les valérie bonsoir à vos
différents invités ce soir nous allons
avoir quelques conseils pour limiter la
facture électrique notamment on va voir
ça dans un instant avec cette période de
grand froid nous verrons aussi comment
maîtriser justement toute cette
consommation électrique du côté de herdt
auparavant une autre attitude citoyenne
à prendre le covoiturage quels avantages
vous avez enquêté on se retrouve ensuite
sur le plateau
18h heure de sortie des bureaux et aux
heures de pointe sur les routes sylvie
massucci assistante travaux chez
bouygues construction à guyancourt se
dirige vers le parking de l'entreprise
direction les places réservées au
covoiturage depuis la mi janvier sylvie
a décidé qu'elle ne voyagerait plus seul
dans son véhicule
en premier lieu pour une question
cruciale par ces temps de crise il
cotait financiers essentiellement
ensuite on voit là
le fait de pas faire le trajet tout seul
c'est 60 km c'est quand même seul c'est
quand même assez long donc c'est quand
même assez agréable de pouvoir discuter
avec les gens et non ça se passe bien
mais c'est surtout le côté financier au
départ guyancourt dreux 67 km le
quotidien de celles vie au sein de son
entreprise elle a trouvé trois autres
collègues qui pratiquent le covoiturage
depuis septembre 2012 sylvie potier
également employé chez vous de
construction fait partie de l'équipe
dans l'emploi du temps de chacune s'il
faut s'adapter par rapport à une absence
des congés ont fait des échanges mais en
règle générale c'est une semaine chacune
à l'instar de bouygues construction
d'autres entreprises de l'agglomération
encourage le covoiturage c'est le cas du
groupe malakoff médéric
ici aussi les emplacements sont réservés
pour les covoitureurs mais le concept
peine malgré tout a démarré c'est
vraiment un état d'esprit une question
de mentalité les gens ont du mal à
s'accaparer l'idée qu'on peut co
voiturer qu'on peut voyager à deux ou à
trois ses parents cran rentrer dans nos
moeurs mais faut pas désespérer
la preuve nos deux sylvie ne
renonceraient au covoiturage pour rien
au monde
bravo à ces deux sylvie alors
qu'ils sont lancés dans le covoiturage
on va parler électricité mince n'ont pas
de voiture électrique mais d'électricité
voilà puisque air en ces périodes de
grand froid que nous venons de traverser
on peut se poser la question de savoir
comment gérer
le réseau qui dispense des foyers des
entreprises l'électricité dont nous
avons besoin pour nous chauffer avec
nous sur ce plateau gaëtan desquilbet
directeur régional normandie paris de
rte c'est le réseau
merci qui le moteur et des films pour
filles au chef du service d'exploitation
justement alors comment comment est
gérée l'exploitation du réseau
électrique alors en fait on a des
équipes qui sont en permanence aux
manettes du réseau de transport
d'électricité sont des équipes de quart
qui tourne en trois-huit donc ils sont
là 24 heures sur 24 on a cinq personnes
en permanence qui gère fait ce qu'on
pourra plus une espèce de réseaux
routiers et qui sont aux manettes en
permanence alors nous allons voir avec
des images puisque nous nous sommes
rendus en vo locaux au plus fort de
cette tempête de neige qui nous avons vu
la semaine dernière braver tous les
dangers à la lah avec elodie mois nous
allons regarder tout ça
neige et températures en baisse ont
paralysé les routes ce week end mais pas
le réseau de transport d'électricité en
relation permanente avec météo france
les exploitants du réseau a juste de
façon continue le besoins en
consommation ici dans les locaux du rte
à montigny le bretonneux
les équipes restent sereines nous avons
également actuellement une situation
favorable avec un réseau qui est
globalement très disponible donc une
situation qui nous permet d'affronter
une vague de froid avec un bon espoir et
puis grandes chances que ça se passe
bien le réseau acheminer l'énergie
depuis les centrales jusqu'au point de
consommation à savoir les foyers les
bâtiments publics et les entreprises
actuellement la consommation
d'électricité ici en rouge reste en deçà
des prévisions en bleu on a connu deux
niveaux de consommation beaucoup plus
élevé l'hiver dernier au mois de février
où la vague de froid était plus
rigoureuse ce qu on était dix degrés
sous les températures normales
saisonnières on actuellement à peu près
5 degrés sous les températures normales
saisonnières donc les froids qu'on subit
actuellement sont moins virulents
23 1300 mégawatts consommés l'an dernier
au plus fort de la vague de froid à
l'heure actuelle la consommation n'a pas
encore atteint les 23 1000 mégawatts de
plus la neige sur les toits isole les
maisons et n'entraîne pas de pic de
chauffage mais le manque de luminosité
due à une forte couverture nuageuse
encouragea plus d'éclairage la situation
reste donc stable pour autant les
équipes du rte présente 24 heures sur 24
pour gérer 20% de la demande électrique
française entre l'île de france et toute
la normandie demeurent vigilants météo
france annonce une chute des
températures jusqu'à -4 degrés pour
cette fin de semaine mais là encore la
situation semble déjà maîtrisé les
entreprises étant à l'arrêt les samedis
et dimanches le réseau a alors davantage
de marge de manoeuvre pour chauffer les
foyers
alors comment arrivent les flux commencé
ses dispatcher tout ça dans nos foyers
nos entreprises alors il faut savoir
qu'en région parisienne on est
principalement alimenté par des
centrales qui se trouvent plutôt en
dehors de la région parisienne donc des
centrales de production qu'on trouve en
normandie qu'on trouve également sur la
vallée de la loire et l'électricité qui
est produite par ses centrales va
transiter en fait sur le réseau
d'électricité
pour prendre une image c'est comme si
vous aviez le transit de voitures sera
réseau routier pour se rendre dans une
grande ville c'est un petit peu la même
chose donc ça passe à travers les lignes
électriques
et puis ça arrive voilà étaient les fils
par exemple
sur le plateau voilà
d'accord et donc comment se gèrent la le
pic de consommation
alors ce que vous appelez le pic de
consommation c'est ce qu'on vit en fait
en cette période d'hiver tous les soirs
vers 19h 18h quand on allume la lumière
sur le plateau c'était quoi la voyez à
montigny a rappelé
alors c'est vrai que quand on
quand on observe ce journée diverses et
c'est vrai c'est vraiment 19h où on a
le maximum de consommation électrique
vous arrivez chez vous ou votre conjoint
vous allumer la lumière vous mettez à
préparer la cuisine les enfants aiment
la lumière dans leur chambre et ça fait
un maximum de consommation électrique
est par ailleurs beaucoup de commerces
ou d'entreprises n'ont pas encore fermé
à 19h donc ça fait vraiment un maximum
de consommation d'électricité au même
moment donc sur cette pointe de 19
heures donc c'est vraiment ce doublon
entre les activités professionnelles et
les activités de au sein des foyers qui
provoque ce pic chaque soir et notamment
en hiver particulièrement oui absolument
on voit bien que après 19 heures ça
commence à redescendre ensuite mais avec
le changement d'horaire justement est-ce
que ça sert véritablement à quelque
chose l'heure d'été à l'heure d'hiver
c'est efficace pour ça justement pour
absorber cette différence alors on a une
différence de consommation effectivement
d'électricité entre l'été et l'hiver on
a un pic qui est quand même beaucoup
moins marqué au moment de la soirée
d'été mais aussi parce que en hiver
qu'est ce qui fait qu'on consomme
beaucoup d'électricité à 19 heures on a
beaucoup de chauffage et de chauffage
électrique par donc
aimer la bière enfin et du coup beaucoup
au coût de chauffage qui démarre cette
heure là que se passe-t-il en cas de
panne est ce qu'une panne peut arriver
justement lors d'un fort pic de
consommation d'électricité
une bonne pourrait arriver on n'est
jamais à l'abri d'une panne en fait ce
qu'ils ont craint c'est au moment où on
a beaucoup de consommation d'électricité
à alimenter ce serait par exemple un
arbre qui tombe sur son running qui
transportait de l'électricité
l'électricité qui transitaient par cette
ligne au lieu de passer sur cette ligne
là elle va passer par des itinéraires
bis toujours pour ceux comme les
voitures qui passeraient sur d'autres
itinéraires et ça peut créer des
embouteillages en fait d'accord et donc
quand comment ça se passe dans ces cas
là comment on gère la situation dans ces
cas là donc comme dans le film on voir
les équipes qui sont en place qui
appelle des équipes de secours sur le
terrain qui vont intervenir pour réparer
la ligne et on va aiguiller finalement
l'électricité sur d'autres d'autres
itinéraires en fait en temps réel on
manoeuvre tout depuis cette salle de
commande alors lors de notre visite
gaëtan desquilbet vous nous aviez
précisé que la dernière catastrophe j'ai
envie de dire la dernière partie
est palpitant la dernière panne remonte
à 87 en fait c'est pas lui qui était un
écroulement du réseau comme on dit qui
est partie de l'ouest de la france et
qui atteint jusqu'à l'île de france qui
ne s'est pas répercuté à l'est de paris
mais qui a produit une coupure pendant
pratiquement une journée de plusieurs
dizaines de millions de personnes c'est
relativement rare et ça arrive plus tôt
en cas d'incident extérieur on parlait
de la chute d'un arbre mais aussi de la
tempête de 99 plutôt que d'un pic de
consommation or depuis on a eu des
incidents qui ont fait des coupures mais
en général localiser et c'était lié à
des aléas climatiques il ya eu dans
d'autres pays du monde des coupures il
ya des fortes consommations il y en a
eus aux états unis en 2002 en italie
aussi en 2003 il y en a eu récemment en
inde au brésil où ils ont des
augmentations de consommation galopante
comme ce qu'on vivait en france dans les
30 années d'après guerre les trente
glorieuses et ils vivent un
développement de consommation que la
production n'arrive pas à suivre donc
ils ont eu un équilibre très délicat à
gérer et chez eux c'est quand il fait
chaud qui ne s'allume des climatiseurs
donc en france c'est le froid et les
chauffages électriques
juste pour une petite parenthèse
aujourd'hui pas de souci à se faire dans
la région ile de france parce qu'il n'ya
pas avoir une explosion à venir de la
double urbanisation de la crise alors
aujourd'hui c'est à dire dans les
quelques années qui viennent on est sera
jusqu'en 2015 au delà il ya des
phénomènes sur lequel on a pas encore
d'informations en terme d'ampleur ça
pourrait être le véhicule électrique par
exemple s'il y avait réellement 2
millions de véhicules électriques en
2020 comme ce qui est prévu dans les
politiques environnementales
ça te conduire est suivant les modalités
de recharge à éventuellement accentuer
les pics parce que si les gens recharge
de voitures électriques en rentrant du
bureau à 19 heures ça va encore se
rajouter si recharge la nuit de dix
heures du soir à 5 heures du matin ça
sera très bien parce que ça va gueuler
des centrales qui de toute façon sont
pas en plein régime à ces heures là donc
on surveille de près et il ya
probablement beaucoup de développements
techniques technologiques à faire pour
que ces recharge de véhicules
électriques se fasse intelligemment donc
ça c'est un des enjeux des prochaines
années on voit aussi des reports de
consommation de fioul ou de gaz vers
l'électricité qui qui se sont beaucoup
produit ces dernières années qu'ils
peuvent se prolonger dans la cuisson par
exemple dans des utilisations
domestiques de l'énergie alors l'hiver
n'est pas terminé pour un temps même si
on a eu un hiver relativement doux pour
l'instant vous êtes en perpétuelle
relation avec les services de météo
france bien sûr bien sûr nous sommes un
des gros utilisateurs des données qu'ils
fournissent sur veut des horizons qui
vont à peu près deux semaines donc au
delà c'est difficile de prévoir est ce
que le mois de mars sera d'un froid
rigoureux au plus tôt d'où ça on n'en
sait rien mais à court terme sur les
jours qui viennent on sait parfaitement
prédire la température est également la
production éolienne puisqu'on a des
données relatives au vent alors plutôt à
deux ou trois jours d'anticipation donc
on calcule l'equilibre production
consommation et on sait assez bien le
gérer donc pour l'instant on a une
vision tout à fait optimiste pour les
prochains jours mais si une vague de
froid se produisait en mars qui pourrait
doubler à des aléas par exemple de
centrales de production indisponibles on
a toujours le risque d'être très tangent
sur l' équilibre production consommation
alors quels sont les conseils qu'on peut
donner aux particuliers notamment pour
les responsabiliser quant à leur
consommation d'électricité aujourd'hui
alors peut-être juste avant de répondre
moi peut-être écouté les salles à ce que
l'on m'a posé la même question voilà
nous est coupée dans intéressant vous
maîtrisez vous votre consommation
électrique nous vous avons posé la
question et puis ensuite on va écouter
vos précieux conseils on espère alors
oui on fait attention on éteint les
lumières quand on n'est pas dans les
pièces on essaye de ne pas trop chauffer
franchement non non
j'utilise qu'angers utilise bien sûr que
j'ai fait attention et j'ai les pires
embêtements depuis que j'ai demandé une
installation d'une pompe à chaleur les
appareils qui soi-disant doivent rester
en veille je les états qu'on coupe le
chauffage la nuit qu'on laisse pas les
lumières allumées
après bon ça vient des gestions de toute
façon on a relevé de compteur se font
maintenant soi même donc moi j'ai pris
ce système ce qui me permet déjà de plus
sensibilisés à la consommation en ayant
une vue exacte de ce que je consomme les
four rise up électrique j'ai fait
attention aussi j arrête avant la fin de
la cuisson je baisse les convecteurs la
nuit je met en mode éco
j'éteins des lampes qui en a trop
d'allumer je fais très attention quand
je passe de pièce en pièce
éteindre le four avant la fin de la
cuisson éteindre la lumière dès qu'on
sort de la pièce ça ça semble plutôt du
bon sens mais pour le four par exemple
c'est une bonne idée oui parce que je
suis en fait les équipements qui
consomment le plus d'électricité c'est
physiquement qui chauffe et après les
équipements qui ont des moteurs donc
l'aspirateur le lave linge lave
vaisselle et vous avez ensuite pour
l'éclairage ça consomme un peu moins
quand même ans a fait une ampoule ça
consomme 10 à 20 fois moins qu'un sur
toile et un matériel d'éclairage tous
les nouveaux systèmes donc l'éclairage
devient un peu moins pertinent et enfin
lors vous avez des fêtes consommation
quand vous brancher un téléphone pour le
recharger ou physiquement entre
votre iphone que voilà cette fois ci
passer l'aspirateur
voilà donc conseillé de base ne passait
pas l'aspirateur en temps chez vous ne
faites pas du repassage ce cas fer à
repasser ça peut être 750 800 1000 watts
écrit dessus donc une ampoule on disait
s'emboîtent dans le temps 75 watts
maintenant c'est plutôt 32 watt 25
envoyé une ampoule c'est comme il en
faut 40 pour faire l'équivalent d'un fer
à repasser donc repasser le week-end ou
après 21h la nuit
excepté la nuit tout cas du point de vue
de la gestion du réseau électrique c'est
beaucoup plus simple pour nous si ce pic
s'écrase et s'étale donc on en est pas
que les gens se privent forcément mais
si possible qu'ils déplacent les
consommations qui peuvent l'être sans
que ça touche au confort donc lancé un
lave vaisselle si vous le faites à 10
heures du soir en plus si vous avez un
tarif avec des heures creuses la nuit
vous paierez l'énergie moins cher et
c'est fait pour que justement vous
consommiez de l'énergie à des moments où
il ya des centrales qui sont disponibles
pour vous la fournir alors dernière
question justement il ya un test de
responsabilité qui a été effectué en
bretagne et en région paca et ça
fonctionne ça fonctionne bien donc ça a
démarré il ya cinq ans en bretagne il ya
deux ans et pas qu'à ça s'appelle
ecowatt où l'idée est de responsabiliser
les gens les particuliers les citoyens
on leur donne comme un feu de
circulation vert orange rouge suivant
l'état du réseau il faut voir ce sont
deux régions très particulière c'est les
seuls en france qui sont ce qu'on
appelle des péninsules électriques donc
des régions où il ya très peu de
productions et des longues lignes du
réseau pour les alimenter donc le signal
ça dépend de l'état de charge des lignes
du réseau quand elle arrive près de la
saturation on en voit une lumière orange
quand elles sont au niveau limite c'est
le feu rouge et ça se double de conseils
pour que les gens réduisent la
consommation et la déplace à l'heure de
pointe du soir donc ce qu'on vient de
dire inquiet très important que je
voudrais redire c'est tout bête c'est de
fermer les volets de tirer les rideaux
par rapport au chauffage ça améliore
beaucoup l'isolation de votre maison
donc si vous avez des votes des volets
au lieu de laisser là simplement la
fenêtre
fermez les volets vous tirez les rideaux
vous verrez vous ferait beaucoup
d'économies de chauffage électrique ou
pas d'ailleurs mettez un pull aussi la
l'on peut bouffer à 19 degrés au lieu de
21 degrés france et les soirs d'hiver en
mettons impulse et ça c'est très
efficace également tout l'économiser 30%
en baissant de 2 degrés voilà de
précieux conseils
à nous parler de l'activité de rt
valérie on poursuit avec un petit agenda
une date oui et justement comment
concevoir son habitat de façon
écologique ce sera le thème de
l'exposition habitat écologique de la
théorie à la pratique proposée par la
maison de l'environnement à partir du 5
février et jusqu'au 23 mars de 14 heures
à 18 heures une exposition pour trouver
tous les conseils pour restaurer isolé
et aménager son habitacle la maison de
l'environnement à magny les hameaux
merci valérie à votre place dans
quelques minutes catherine mulato pour
un compte rendu des voeux du maire
d'elancourt mais déjà cette question
doit-on aimé tout le monde c'est curieux
mais des enfants de 7 à 11 ans ont
planché sur ce sujet à l'occasion d'un
atelier philo à magny les hameaux
l'atelier se déroule une fois par mois
et le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est
que les enfants ont toujours des choses
à raconter
une question qu'a l'air
à la fois très faim aurait pu très
compliqué et donc c'est pour ça qu'on y
réfléchisse ensemble et de voir si on
peut trouver des réponses
anne-sophie chillar est journaliste et
animatrice de l'atelier de philosophie
de magny les hameaux une fois par mois
une dizaine d'enfants de 7 à 12 ans
philosophe pendant une heure ce qu'on
fait en atelier se pisse on pratique
philosophique c'est à dire c'est pas du
tout une approche par rapport à des
auteurs ou à des textes philosophiques
c'est plutôt manier la pensée et essayer
de décortiquer un peu des questions
philosophiques que les enfants se pose
naturellement de l'arizona ainsi
pourquoi existons à quoi sert l'histoire
qu'est ce qui est juste sont des thèmes
abordés lors de ces ateliers expliqué qu
aux enfants que ces questions là elle
sont universelles que les hommes se les
pose depuis toujours et à n'importe quel
âge de la vie et qu'il n'y a pas de
réponse toute faite qu'il y a des grands
penseurs qui ont déjà réfléchi mais que
chacun à son niveau en fait est amené à
y réfléchir et d'un intérêt de des
ateliers c'est qu'on y réfléchisse en
communauté le sujet de l'atelier de
samedi dernier
faut-il aimer tout le monde mazarine 12
ans a sa petite idée et messi ont
l'après si on veut passer du temps avec
lui et il va alors que respecter si on
lui dit pas de mal et on ne fait pas mal
physiquement moralement la question du
jour est écrite sur un tableau par anne
sophie après quelques minutes de
réflexion les enfants lèvent la main
prennent la parole avec un dictaphone
aux mains et donnent leur avis sur le
sujet
l'intérêt de cet atelier est donc de
réfléchir en communauté et de prendre
confiance en soi le prochain atelier
aura lieu le 23 février sur le thème à
quoi servent les copains